after two years at sea kid has failed
the King of England he hasn't taken any
pirate treasure or captured ships
belonging to Britain's enemy at the
French kid changes course and heads for
the Red Sea where pirates are known to
prey on wealthy Muslim pilgrims Kidd
would let the pirate capture the ship
and then Kidd would capture the pirate
but typical kids luck he doesn't find a
pirate ship he sails back toward India
and lo and behold the key to merchant
appears the key to merchant is 350 tons
it's carrying goods for some very
wealthy Armenian merchants bales of silk
and other fine fabrics it's even has
rubies and diamonds the board's got 80
chests of opium and this is a heck of a
capture and he does it through a ruse de
guerre through a trick of the flag he
flies the French flag they respond with
a French pass and it is a legal
privateering capture kid believes the
opposing ship to be French but it isn't
that simple
the quedagh merchant is actually a
multinational venture with Indian and
British financial interests Kidd
accidentally captures one of Britain's
own when the King of England hears of
the capture EB trace kid and declares
him a rogue pirate
kid believes the capture of the quedagh
merchant to be legal and prepares for
the long journey home in his leaky ship
he decides the adventure galley is not
seaworthy he burns it for its iron work
and anything else of value and he reef
it's the key to merchant with the 34 or
as many guns as has maybe 30 guns of the
adventure galley and he takes the extra
cannons that were on the kita merchant
and puts him in the hold for ballast
Kidd sails the quedagh merchant to the
Caribbean in search of supplies with
great seamanship and great stealth he
succeeds in getting back to Anguilla in
the Caribbean which at the time was
British and he expects a fairly warm
welcome he is pulled off the near
impossible and he finds out that he is
the most wanted pirate in the British
Empire and he's flabbergasted stunned
it's just horrible
kid is desperate to avoid the British
Royal Navy he flees to Hispaniola and
Catalina Island to plan his next move
located off the southeast corner of
Hispaniola Catalina is a small island
measuring just four square miles the
wreck site spans nearly 30 yards from
end to end on the windward side of the
island
cannons stack leg cargo bear an eerie
resemblance to what researchers believe
is a ballast pile on the wreck site
today marine archeologist frits
Hanselman tries to make sense of the
piles orientation and then chooses
cannons for excavation was this main
pile of cannons and you can look here on
the map or what you have here is you
have your cannons arranged in
alternating fashion you have cascabel
running the south and then the next
cannon would have the muzzle running to
the south and then the following cannon
is alternating again like that and one
of them even has the trunnions up like
this they're stacked like how we would
pack our shoes in a suitcase
you know you alternate so it fits better
and this is very indicative of actually
having cannons as cargo or in the hole
they could use it as ballast or things
of that nature
underneath the cannon we have a series
of anchors and in archival information
it says that Captain Kidd had 14 to 15
anchors it's part of the scrap metal
when these are not deployable anchors
these are anchors that were cargo if
beakers theory is correct it would match
kids description of the quedagh merchant
it's July 3rd of 1699 he's making a
statement about his voyage he winds up
saying exactly what is the board the key
to merchants
a hundred and fifty bales seventy or
eighty tons of sugar about ten tons of
iron in short junks about 14 or 15
anchors forty tons of saltpeter about 20
guns in the hole and 30 guns mounted
being the guns lately belonging to the
adventure galley then built at Sarat by
the Moors all her seams are rabbited and
it's signed William KITT this is the key
document for trying to absolutely
determine whether or not this is Captain
Kidd's shipwreck